let's now go back to Norah on Capitol
Hill and Norah drama is a word I never
thought that we would see the day where
gang rape and Supreme Court nominee are
even remotely in the same sentence it is
shaping up to be quite a day you're
right and that's what makes this hearing
that we are gonna see today so
extraordinary and why I've heard from so
many people that they not only view this
as historic but must watch television
because what essentially the Anita Hill
hearings 27 years ago set off in terms
of a year of the woman that change about
this discussion about sexual harassment
in the workplace I'm joined now by
senator dick durbin a member of the
Senate Judiciary Committee who will be
involved in this questioning today let's
start first with dr. Blasi for this is
the first time we are going to see her
in person and hear from her what do you
know about what she is going to testify
to today
Norah first let's put in context can you
imagine this first time where NPR
reports six out of ten Americans say I
want to be tuned in and watch this the
pressure on dr. Ford for her first
appearance you know Judge Cavanaugh was
under pressure too but he's an old hand
at Washington and how this works in
judicial hearings but she's under
extraordinary pressure and I've read her
opening statement where she says
flat-out I'm terrified I hope that we
take that into consideration
both the Republican prosecutor as well
as members on the Democratic side she's
not a Republican prosecutor she's an
independent prosecutor that the
Republicans have chosen we should point
that out an experienced sex crimes
prosecutor she'll be doing the
questioning for the Republicans why
wouldn't the Democratic senators agree
to let just her handle it so we could
have a hearing that it doesn't involve
politics well I think it's naive to
believe that because they've chosen a
prosecutor from Arizona politics are not
part of the equation and we happen to
believe on the Democratic side we were
elected to this committee we are having
a responsibility under the Constitution
to advise and consent and asking our
questions is part of the decision
process the Republican senators for a
variety reasons who decided otherwise
let's talk now about judge Kavanagh
because
today will decide his fate in many ways
especially among some of those
Republican senators specifically women
Murkowski and Collins who have not yet
decided how they will vote I want to
show you the Facebook page of Brett
Kavanaugh that we have looked at in
which he talks about being on the
football team being on basketball but he
also lists a lot of things that he did
in terms of drinking and women he may
have dated in terms of high school is
that relevant of course it is because
we're talking about an incident that may
have occurred while he was in high
school so knowing what his high school
experience was what he did what he said
the lifestyle at that moment in time is
totally relevant to whether or not this
might have occurred are you gonna ask
him about his sex life well I'm not
going to get into the details of what
I'm going to ask at this point oh really
I mean really what we're gonna have here
we're really gonna talk ask a judge
who's sitting on the DC Circuit Court
about his sex life I don't plan to ask
you about that but I'm not going to tell
you what I'm gonna go into because we
have five minutes five minutes so it
certainly is going to be an irrelevant
question I hope to understanding whether
he is implicated in this or not but I
have to do it in the context of what's
been asked before me and how little time
I have to try to develop a line of
question are you gonna ask him about
some of the other accusations that have
been made against him by women other
than dr. Ford I think whatever it may be
gonna zero in on especially is the fact
that this judge this man who in the
White House was marshalling all of these
judicial nominations for year after year
has refused an FBI investigation he says
I have nothing to do with this yet if
the Eaton believes there's no evidence
and no witnesses
why wouldn't he support an FBI
investigation it would have cleared it
we may never have had this hearing
instead he's stonewalled said no FBI
investigation and we're not gonna call
the one person it was my close friend
referred to in my yearbook mark judge
who's at a Bethany Beach hideaway we're
not going to subpoena him only dr. Foley
and let me just show you a picture of
your college you're the number two on
the Senate Judiciary Committee Dianne
Feinstein is the ranking member there's
picture that's gone viral of her almost
Lyndon Johnson s with her arm up talking
to Republican senator Lisa Murkowski
who's a swing vote here are your
colleagues lobbying senator Collins and
Senator Murkowski lobbying is too strong
a word you know we have respect for our
colleagues on both sides of the aisle
and those who believe you can twist arms
in the Senate you just don't understand
the modern Senate each of these
individual senators on both sides is
going to make a personal historic
decision do we discuss the issue of
course senator I'm gonna yield the floor
now as you would say to my colleagues
John Dickerson and Gayle King who are in
our studio John all right I thank the
gentlelady from Texas senator durbin
we've been talking about Republicans and
what they're thinking but there are a
number of Democrats who are still up in
the air about this
what's your guidance to those Democrats
and do you think any of them will vote
for judge Kavanagh well I've spoken to
most of them and I will tell you John
that they are watching the hearing with
the rest of America they are waiting to
see the facts that come out they're
going to draw their own conclusions
about the credibility of dr. Ford as
well as Judge Cavanaugh so I would say
many of them are undecided at this
moment which Democrat most the Democrats
have decided there's just a few swing
votes igg
those are the few were watching senator
durbin thank you so much for joining us
we appreciate it
good to be with you all right John and
Gail oh I'll send it back to you guys in
the studio all right Thank You Nora